hello i'm brady and it's me who makes
the videos here on 60 symbols which
means normally it's also me who gets to
ask the questions how cold are we
talking here how cold is an ultra cold
atom that's a good question i'll write
it down as well
tell me how that thing works
um sorry brady oh fantastic yeah this is
amazing however believe it or not we're
about to cover our 100th symbol and to
celebrate the occasion we've decided to
try something a little bit different we
want you to ask the questions
did schrodinger actually ever own a cat
i don't know i really don't know so if
there's anything you'd like to ask any
of our physicists or astronomers send us
the question
you can either submit it by email
here's the address
or you can just leave a comment here on
the youtube video
however i'll keep the questions a secret
until i actually ask them you can ask
whatever you want but i have got one bit
of advice
don't ask something technical or factual
you could just get from a textbook or on
wikipedia why not be creative and ask
something a bit different see if you can
ask one of these men or women a question
they've never been asked before no
please brady no no no no
don't beg me